>>My name is Luis.
I'm eighteen years old.
I live in Cornelius, Oregon.
>>Luis: I really enjoy technology,
because it's a better way to connect
with families, connect with friends,
better way to help me improve
my studies, better way to find
out information and
use that information
for the community,
not just for myself.
>>Luis: In the morning, I
wake up around five thirty.
I usually turn on the computer,
check email just really quick,
go downstairs, have breakfast.
Wake up my brother, make sure
he gets ready for school.
We would go out the door maybe
around seven twenty in the morning.
I drop him off at school
and then I go to school.
I'm taking the four AP classes,
advanced placement
classes, in one day.
>>Teacher: -- it shows,
the taller the bar,
the more frequent it happened.
>>Luis: Basically, when I get home,
right away I'm checking my Gmail
and this is the one
I use for friends.
So then after this, it's social
networking, so I go to Facebook,
check what my friends are doing.
My friend Ellie, she's become
a fan of Cheez-Its, apparently.
If a friend's online, I can
start chatting with them.
If you're just instant messaging.
>>You could be writing a
paper here and then chatting
with your friends at the same time.
>>So that's definitely good for
connecting with people and not just
through like old fashioned
ways like letters or telephone.
>>Go to CNET dot com.
So naturally they have how-to videos
and this is where I learn a lot
about computers and installing
different operating systems.
I also spend a lot
of time on YouTube.
This video, we made it for fun and my
little brother and I would just like,
whenever we had really
nothing to do, I'm like,
"Why don't you start dancing like
a robot and see how that looks?"
>>It's pretty funny.
>>Luis: [speaking Spanish].
>>Mom: Okay.
>>Luis: Both my mom and my
dad are from a state in Mexico
by the name of Michoacan.
They both came here as just rural
immigrants, looking for jobs,
looking for a place to work.
>>Lucy: Luis, he's kinda
quiet guy, reserved,
but you can tell he's thinking a lot.
He's a good son.
And when I saw that he picks up
his brother, his mom and does--
helps her out with all these things,
you know, I as a mother think, "Wow,
I would like that as a son."
>>Luis: My parents, they said the
only time they ever used technology
was the ATM.
>>Luis: And then after that,
them my mom asked me to put
like the soap operas on, on YouTube.
>>Mom: Oh, yes.
>>Teacher: This is the
score that falls right
in the middle of all of your scores.
So if you have--
>>Luis: On a Monday or on
a Thursday, I usually stay
after school to do extra work.
And on Wednesdays is when I
have the Tech Wizards program.
>>Lisa: The Intel 4-H
Tech Wizards is an
after school tiered mentoring
program that introduces
under represented youth to education
pathways and careers, in science,
technology, engineering and math.
>>Cecilia: -- the interview,
it's right there.
And then what kind of shots
you're gonna be doing,
close up, medium, long shot.
>>The majority of the students
know about technology nowadays.
They use iPads, they use cell
phones, they use video cameras.
They use their computers.
So we use those tools kind of
like the hook for the program.
>>Luis: Five, four...
>>Luis: We divide into groups and
each group did their own project.
And it could either be related to
something fun like a music video,
or something more in depth,
like a community project,
like filming the local flea
market, which is what we did.
>>Lisa: In the beginning,
what we try to do is motivate.
And then if all things come
together as they should, pretty soon,
we're just trying to
get out of the way.
>>Student on video:
[speaking Spanish].
>>Lisa: Because you
have started something.
>>Luis: The Tech Wizards,
they decided to do a project
on the street trees, and we do it
with a partnership with the City
of Hillsboro, that's called
Street Tree Inventory Project
which is evaluating the
conditions of the trees
and then reporting to the city.
The information we collected
included the species of the tree.
We collected its height, its width,
the canopy size, the conditions.
>>Lisa: He was selected to go do
a presentation in Santiago, Chile.
Where he's gonna be doing a world
class presentation, literally.
I always ask the kids,
"What was the best part?"
and I assume that they might say,
"Oh, travel," or something like that.
No. The best part was doing
the presentation and realizing
that he had the capability
now to do something like this.
>>Luis: Okay, that
motor's right here.
It controls the steering.
>>Cecilia: Lego robotics is another
project where the students learn how
to use math, science and engineering.
>>Luis: What would you like for it?
Like you want it to be the
fastest, the strongest?
>>Cecilia: Each student works
with an elementary student,
and they teach them how
to program their robots.
>>Luis: And then let's see how
it looks, and then you can start
like building the catapillar.
>>They're not just learning about the
technology of how to build robots,
but they're learning
about working together.
I think that's the
most important part.
And those are like skills
that I believe should be
learned at an early age.
>>It's like automatic everything.
You have to program it.
So that's like one of the key things.
You just can like move it
with the remote control
and make it go forward
and then go back.
You have to like think
out in advance.
>>We teach them how to build,
how to program and how to compete
in a tournament that
takes place every year.
>>My parents always ask me like,
"Why are you staying all
the time after school?
Like, why don't you ever come home?"
I'm like, "I'm trying
to help other people,
I'm trying to help the community."
And once they actually came
and saw what I was doing,
they said, "All right, yeah."
>>Luis: Being the first person
in my family to go to college,
or planning to go to college
definitely like excites me.
>>All these opportunities I've
gotten, I realize that it's
because of others that I have them.
I just didn't stumble upon them.
Others presented them to me,
and I took advantage of them.
>>The first time I remember using
computers, maybe in kindergarten.
After that, I went through a
lot of like older computers,
I bought like at thrift stores and
garage sales, and I opened them up
and see what were inside.
But when I bought my own
computer, which was maybe
about four years ago,
it took that long.
I was like, I kept nagging my parents
for years to buy me a computer,
but once they bought it, you know, I
started like trying to do everything.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org